wielding loves violet light Carol Ferris
battles alongside Green Lantern a star
sapphire keeper of the savage predator a
beastly blaster Star Sapphire is capable
of lane dominance through long-range
damage
her passive is glimpse of the predator
star sapphire is accompanied by the
incorporeal predator and her skills make
it - between targets when dashing the
predator deals power damage to all
enemies encountered if the predator is
attached to star sapphire she gains new
speed use crystal bomb to create a
crystal at the target location when
placed the predator dashes to the
crystal which explodes once the predator
reaches it dealing area-of-effect power
damage
violet harvest deals power damage in an
area around the predator who dashes back
and reattaches two star sapphire star
sapphire gains bonus power damage for
every enemy champion struck bonds of
love is a skill shot able to hit her
predator or her enemies after hitting
its first target bonds of love bounces
to the nearest target and links the two
targets can break the bond by moving
away from each other enemies struck by
the projectile or the bounce take power
damage up front and then ongoing power
damage as long as the bond is intact you
can activate bonds of love a second time
to pull the bond two targets together
per ultimate is manifest on activation
the predator phases into reality for an
extended length of time and briefly
routes nearby enemies it will auto
attack any nearby enemies otherwise you
can reactivate manifests to give the
predator movement and attack commence
while manifested the predator will still
- when she uses her skills and it's
dashes deal extra damage but it cannot
attach to her Star Sapphire skills have
fantastic synergy when being chased or
at risk of being chased save violet
harvest to attach the crystal and
increase your move speed you can also
use bonds of love to attach a pursuer to
her predator when manifested the
predator has multiple uses crystal bond
the target and the predator will charge
into that space damaging enemies along
the way and then Auto attacking the
nearest target crystal bombs low
cooldown allows you to continue the
chase by placing a second one ahead of
your target you can also use bonds of
love to capture foes fleeing from a
teamfight pulling someone back into your
teamfight can be far more lethal than a
second crystal bomb mil ring can give
you a well-rounded laning phase and
going for star heart early will boost
damage output the augmented basic attack
with sized scimitar can kill great first
two enemies after using the skill heavy
use of crystal bomb can take a toll on
will so consider Abin SURS lantern for
the bonus will and regeneration star
sapphire sacrifices durability for great
offense
so consider a defensive items such as
neurons contract racial ghouls rope or
entropy ages star sapphires unique
stolen power is psychic assault in
addition to slowing a targets move speed
this power reduces their incoming
healing this is especially useful when
chasing a low health champion attempting
to restore health while escaping
fight with loves fire and prey on
hateful hearts as the tenacious star
sapphire
you